hay novedades sobre el caso del
futbolista ecuatoriano byron castillo y
muchas selecciones de sudamérica atentas
a lo que ocurrió hoy con la fifa porque
temen que puede haber algún cambio en
esta clasificación a la copa mundo de
qatar-2022 empecemos el comité de
apelación de la fifa desestimó el
recurso presentado por las federaciones
de fútbol de chile perú y ratificó el
archivo de la causa en torno a la
presunta alineación indebida del jugador
ecuatoriano byron castillo esto reafirma
ecuador en el mundial de qatar-2022
torneo en el que además participará en
su partido inaugural para analizar este
tema conectamos con antonio quintero
abogado especialista en derecho del
deporte quien nos atiende desde la
ciudad de caracas señor antonio quintero
muchas gracias por estar con nosotros
porque decide el comité de apelación
mantener su decisión y archivar la
denuncia de chile y perú
oye muchísimas gracias por la
oportunidad y bueno es un tema bastante
complejo no se sabe exactamente la razón
por la cual mantiene la decisión pero
podemos imaginarnos un par de razones
por las cuales se mantiene la decisión
primero hay que decir que en este caso
en
tribunal de ecuador que dictó una
decisión indicando que va a ir a un
castillo tenía una nacionalidad
ecuatoriana es muy difícil que la fifa
pueda decidir en contra de esta decisión
del tribunal de ecuador primero porque
es una materia de orden público en
ecuador la nacionalidad de uno de sus
ciudadanos o no el segundo porque la
fifa no tiene la posibilidad de
abrir un caso que ha cerrado en ecuador
y cambiar esa decisión sólo puede
aceptar esta decisión como tal ese es el
gran problema que tiene este caso que
así el propio byron castillo diga que él
es colombiano así encuentra en todas las
pruebas posibles tienen que ir a cambiar
una decisión es de jugador y si esa
decisión en ecuador cambia pudieran
cambiar algunas cuestiones pero no la la
clasificación de ecuador and dial y por
qué no puede cambiar la clasificación de
ecuador al mundial bueno básicamente
porque en cualquier momento de ecuador
si la federación ecuatoriana simplemente
puede decir yo estaba siguiendo lo que
era un documento válido en el momento
que ocurrieron los partidos
aún en el peor caso posible ecuador no
quedaría fuera del mundial aún cuando
iron llegará a ser sancionado el poder
no quedaría fuera del mundial por las
razones ya explicadas